any kind of art discipline I think the
possibilities are endless I think we
this life is so brief and and we spend
it sometimes imposing over ourselves so
many limitations we underestimated five
to three Colombian girls
there is inspire cutter is she's a
Colombian singer songwriter dancer and
becquer producers her song hips don't
lie
is one of the best-selling singles of
the 21st century she has a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame and is one of the
best-selling Latin artists of all time
she's Shakira and here's my take on her
top ten rules for success rule number
one is my personal favorite and I'd love
to know which one you guys like the best
also guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired also when you write it
down it's much more likely to lock in
for yourself as well
enjoy
you know I grew up in Colombia Colombia
is a developing country where a lot of
people don't have access to the most
basic needs and where education is
considered a luxury unfortunately
because we all know that education is a
birthright and and I just grew up
frustrated seeing seeing how many people
weren't able to to realize their own
dreams you know when I was 8 years old
my dad underwent an economic crisis the
financial crisis you know he lost his
business and we struggled economically
for many years we lost our car we lost
our furniture and I remember vividly the
day I walked in my house and all the
furniture was gone because my head had
my dad had to pay his debt and it was
quite well shocking for me you know I
was 8 6 7 8 years old and and when I saw
this I was so frustrated and my dad
I felt upset with my parents because I
couldn't understand how they did so
poorly in business you know I'm like why
why you know I couldn't I couldn't get
it and my dad and my mom took me to the
part where they showed me other kids my
age sniffing glue they were orphaned
they had no one to watch after them and
they were barefoot and they were
abandoned to their unlock and it
probably left such an impression in my
impressionable mind at that age that I
remember that day and remember that I
made myself a promise I said I said to
myself Shakira you have to succeed
because you have to you have to ride in
a car again one day you know you you
have to get your own car someday you and
and I wanted to vindicate my parents
socially and economically and I also
wanted to someday do something for those
kids - I saw that day in the park
so as soon as I had my first big success
with a
Descalzos which was my third album I
decided to establish my own foundation
and do my own contribution to to the
change even if it was going to be a
small one but I wanted to be active and
that's how it all started you know going
through my own financial struggle and
the struggle of my family and
understanding that the one thing that I
never lacked was care protection and an
education and that's probably what made
me thrive in life I didn't know exactly
how this album was going to turn out you
know you can never predict those kind of
things and and there's nothing scarier
than standing in front of white canvas
you never know if you're going to be
able to provide something new to to
those who expect it but you know in any
kind of art discipline I think the
possibilities are endless and and that's
something that always learned the hard
way with every album you know because
I've suffered through the process
sometimes I'm like I'm never going to do
anything that like on - boom it appears
magically you know like I guess if you
keep rubbing the lamp the genius of the
lamp is got to show up at some time this
has been my experience throughout the
years with every album I get really
really nervous the first month in the
studio searching exploring trying things
that sometimes don't work until you find
a magic you know or the magic finds you
while you're working so when you meet
new talent emerging talent and you're
mentoring them if what if you don't have
a confidence that they have the level of
talent required to achieve greatness how
do you counsel them what do you say to
make them feel confidence and not rob
them of that moment but also steer them
in the right direction I mean you can't
say you really you're zero by talking to
them understanding what their concerns
are what what sort of self-image they
have
and I'm trying to to show them their
strengths too and if they have some kind
of weakness while trying to you know not
focus on those weaknesses I think an
entertainment industry that's that's
what works you know you you know your
strengths you milk them you know you you
know your weaknesses you try not to
focus on them so much so that the
audience doesn't focus on them as much
I'm more worried now about being true to
myself I'm being honest and you know
maybe ten years ago I would have not
done a video like she-wolf but now it's
something I feel like doing you know so
what am I going to deprive myself or
deny myself the possibility of
expressing the way I feel I want to
express myself freely I don't I don't
want to be in a golden cage anymore I
don't want to be put behind bars yeah I
think this life is so brief and and we
spend that sometimes imposing over
ourselves so many limitations and
obstacles that don't allow us to grow as
we would like to you know and and yes I
guess still you know very much like a
woman this time around I I wanted to
show my legs I never showed my legs to
it you know for 20 years and I always I
always did all my performances with long
pants and really very not never showed
my legs and one day I looked at them I
said hey they're not bad they're kind of
short but they take me to places I think
it's now or never you know it's about
time to really embrace my individuality
and my freedom as a woman as a person
and that's a message that I encourage to
other women and that doesn't mean
necessarily letting yourself being
objectified because that means
satisfying the desires of other people
you know I say satisfy your own desires
you know and live your life to the
fullest because it's short and all these
awards after winning so many Grammys and
the rest of it
what sort of motivate to you to create
new things new music you know I
shouldn't be this motivated you know
because after so many years I should be
a little bit more calm about everything
but I love what I do and I'm always
putting myself in front of new
challenges and I guess I'm still hungry
am I going to discover the talents that
my son has and how am I going to
encourage him you know to follow his own
dreams and it's it's a conundrum and
it's a and it's a challenge for every
parent out there I think but if it
weren't because of my mom I think that I
would have never made it because she
realized that I was talented but not
only that she supported me she believed
in me and and she went ahead and helped
me help me build my confidence you know
my own confidence confidence in myself
which is a vital tool that you need in
order to survive any kind of job why do
you think why do you think it all came
together for you why lots of hard work
lots of determination I consider myself
a labor of what I do in artisan and I
think I've been building my career
putting a break over a break under the
Sun with sweat and hard work that's the
way I've done it and I haven't given up
not one moment and the must there must
be something very abnormal about this
because it seems so many years doing
this and I still care so much and I
think that's normal you know but with
every project I feel that I haven't
accomplished anything that I feel that
I'm starting from zero and I care
tremendously in a way that sometimes it
surprises me so you feel like you owe
yourself over and over again yes I think
that I have to be that I have to embrace
new challenges
and and those challenges make me grow
and grow and is feeling the way to go
and build a way to I conceive life you
know so yeah that's the way I see it I
think that we all come to this world
with a star with the talents and with a
gift and then later dreams are born and
no one absolutely no one has the
authority to stop those dreams you know
when I was seven years old I came to the
fabula for the first time and I passed
by the walk of fame with my mother and a
friend of hers who's actually here with
us today and and I remember that my mom
told me Jackie one day you're going to
have your name on this place if someone
would have overheard this conversation
they would have thought that my mom was
delirious but she was not and here we
are so I want to say to all of you to
dream as big as you can because in this
country everything is possible
you sound so passionate about so many
diverse pieces of your life that the big
question is you juggle all that like how
do you make all of that happen and
successfully from your music career to
being your mom to being a life partner
to like all of that is so hard to juggle
how do you do it with the secret behind
that I don't know how I'm gonna keep
doing it is a good question because with
the baby things things tend to change a
lot but you know have a great team
people who understand me very well who
understand my cause my my commitments
and and who support him and make my life
easier so it is very important to be
well surrounded your perfect secure your
perfect she is the perfect woman but to
talk about women
come on tell me me oh damn it okay
there's nothing worse than being scolded
by Shakira when she goes from zero to
100 you're not going to get a word in
you and Millie the model of my heart you
know what other things are gonna get on
this subject issue
you never get into an argument with a
Latin woman oh no no no no no no you
don't mess with Shakira don't debate
with her a home on time also how about
sure I'm not the complicated this I'm up
while she's talking shut up
how do I say something all right you're
completely different animal you know you
hospitals under estimated 5 to 3
Colombian girl here is a firecracker
okay so try a spy you're coming to my
team for what make this quick
now without my permission here's what I
do when Shakira starts getting feisty I
do this hi Shakira Mubarak born in thank
you
Halloween for Los Angeles California
hey Adam you know the others had to at
this won't coach for you Walter house
it's hard it's hard to be read all the
time
no no no that's not good are you gonna
Ellen to Jeremy Kelly to Sister Sister
but personally I think it's adorable I
met dynamo it doesn't matter what Sakura
says it's all a drive
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Khalid Azam
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you I'm in the profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know what did Shakira say that has
the biggest impact on you what clip was
your favorite from these ten and also
what are you going to immediately take
from this video and apply somehow to
your life or to your business leave it
down in the comments below and I'm going
to join in the discussion finally I
don't think of a quick shout out to Dan
Purvis dan thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word it
really really really really means a lot
to me and I hope you're enjoying the
read so thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
to be able to succeed in America was
very important represented to me a
reaffirmation as an artist you should
keep it happen original
let's try it performing in VMAs means
freedom means that you really have your
change to do whatever you want on stage
and that it means being among the most
successful artists I could just conquer
my own insecurities and conquer other
hearts
t it will demonstrate that my music was
powerful enough to transcend so many
barriers that are preaching to drop your
jaw drop oh yeah
you want in you wait no no and then you
you know I'm so excited with what we
have now that I would like a VMAs to
happen tonight and I would be ready
oh and falling apart in your hands again
I am the conquer ha ha